welcome back to my tutorial series on
building a data science blog check out
part one and part two if you haven't
already where i show you how to set up
your website and add data science
content for this third and final video
i'm going to show you how we can further
customize your site and really make it
our own but before we get started i will
say that because we use the jekyll blog
we can essentially modify
our site in any way we want so it'd be
impossible for me to cover everything in
just one video
so instead i made a list of some
functional and aesthetic changes i want
to implement and i'm hoping it at least
gives you a general idea of jekyll's
potential so let's get started so once
we have vs code open we can go ahead and
run
our jekyll server so bundle exec jekyll
serve
and we can just take a quick look at our
site so the first change we're going to
make is actually removing this contact
page and instead adding a youtube page
so we'll go back to vs code and because
that element is in our nav bar
that's going to be somewhere and
includes we've got navbar.html
and this is the actual link going to the
contact page
so we're going to change this to youtube
and then instead of
having the href argument going to the
contact page we're going to set it to
our channel link so we'll save that
and we can refresh and now the contact
page is gone and when we click on it
it goes to our youtube page now the next
change is going to be changing the
background on each of our pages so we've
got the home page
the about page and the post page and we
went into changing the background for
different posts so this isn't too
difficult
but let's go over to our image and you
see we have those
pages right here so i'm going to
actually delete all of these
and now i've got some new images that
i'm just going to drag in and
put right in that folder now let's take
a look at that
so we've got our new home background a
new about background
and a post background actually it looks
like our home background isn't showing
up
it should be this image so let's see why
that isn't working let's go to
index.html
and the file name is bg index but ours
is bg home so let's just change that
refresh and now it looks good so our
next change is going to be modifying the
about page
right now it's just lorem ipsum so let's
go ahead and add some content
we'll go to about.html and you can see
right there but instead of modifying
this about.html page directly we're
actually going to
create a new one called about.md
and we'll copy the front matter and
paste it in our md file
and now we can delete this html and the
reason i'm making it a markdown is just
so i can
write in markdown i just think it's
easier for me and then i'm going to
paste
some of my content that i already wrote
just
into this markdown i'm also going to get
rid of the description
and i'll save that and we can go back to
our site
and there we go and then the next change
is going to be removing this posted by
data slice
this appears on the home page on our
post page and then if we go into a post
it appears here
and the reason i want to get rid of it
is because i'm going to be the only one
posting on this site and i just don't
think it's fully necessary
so the easiest way to find the files
that have posted by let's just search
for
posted by and you see it's in our home
in our post and then our index
and we want to remove the posted by data
slice on
so we're just going to delete this right
here
and then we're also going to remove the
posted by to the on
right here and then last is the home
page and we're gonna do the same exact
thing
we'll save it go back and just check
that it changed so it changed on our
home page changed it on our post page
and it changed on our individual posts
and then the next change i want to make
is actually changing this data slice
text into a logo but the tricky thing
here is i'm actually going to use two
different versions of the logo because
right now we have data slice in white
and then if we scroll down and scroll up
a bit there's now this nav bar that
appears again and now all the text is in
black so i'm going to have like a light
version and a dark version of the logo
and i'll show you guys how to deal with
that so i'm first going to drag over the
two versions of the logo i have into our
image folder
and i'll just show you what these look
like so this is the dark version it says
ds
in gray and then this is the light
version you can see it's in white
and we're gonna go back to our
navbar.html and we've got this
a tag with the site title so this is
where it actually says data slice i'm
gonna get rid of that
and i'm gonna create two new tags
they're both gonna be image tags the
source is gonna be
first we're gonna pick the relative path
of the dark logo
and we'll paste it in here but we do
have to make sure that we remember our
slash
we're gonna make the class called logo
dash dark
and then we're going to copy this line
and paste it and then make this the
light version
and this is going to be logo light and
essentially we want to only show the
dark logo
on that white background and the light
logo on the dark background
but if we go back to chrome right now it
shows both of them
so let's go ahead and fix that we're
going to go into our assets folder
into vendor and to our css
and we're going to go to navbar so in
our navbar scss we want to go to navbar
brand which is
what's enclosing the current image tags
we're going to come down here and
specify a new class
logo dark this is what we're using for
the image tags and this is going to be
when we're scrolled up all the way to
the top
so like this we want the light logo to
be displayed
so we're going to make logo dark display
none and then we're going to copy this
paste it and change dark to light and
then make the display
inline save that so we'll go back to
chrome just see
so that looks right and now the only
issue is we need to need to also have it
switched to dark when we scroll back up
and we see this white
so we'll come and copy this and scroll
down a bit
to where we see when the user scrolls
down and we again have that nav bar
brand and it's setting the color to that
dark gray
so we're going to paste this down here
except now we just need to switch
the two display properties so i'll go
ahead and do that
and save it we'll go back to chrome and
that logo looks good and if we scroll up
that logo looks good but the only
problem here is now this nav bar is
actually coming down too much
so let's see if we can go ahead and
inspect the element
and see what's causing that to happen
let me make this full screen
so i'm gonna try to select the nav bar
and i see that there's this property
called top
if i go ahead and play with this number
i can see
we can actually set it and it looks like
90 pixels is about a good spot
so we'll go back to vs code and we see
that right here
so let's make that 67 into 90 and we can
refresh our page
the logo looks good and if we scroll up
the navbar is exactly where we want it
to be
so that's great the next thing is going
to be adding a custom fave icon
to the actual site so right now you see
it's the default one it's just this gray
globe but it's the icon that will appear
on the tab and also if anyone bookmarks
your site it's the icon that the browser
would automatically download so i'd
recommend going to this website
realfaveicongenerator.net all you need
to do is select your icon that you want
to use
i'm going to use this one right here and
essentially it'll do a lot of the grunt
work for you and generate a lot of
different images and the correct scripts
the only important thing is that before
we hit this generate button i actually
don't want to add everything to the root
of my website because i don't want to
make that folder messy so instead i'm
going to come down here and set this to
assets slash fave icon and i'll click
this generate button
and eventually it'll redirect you to
this other page where it'll generate a
package for you to download
it also gives you some steps on what to
do which is pretty nice but we can go
ahead and download this package
and we'll go back to our vs code we're
going to create a new folder under
assets called fave icon but i already
have one right here
and then we're just going to drag in all
these files into there we'll go back to
this site we just need to copy all of
this
go back to vs code and we'll go to our
head.html that has all the links to our
style sheets and any
js that we're using and we can just
paste this at the bottom down here
and i'll save that go back to our data
slice site
refresh and now you see we have the data
slice icon
at the top the next change is going to
be actually modifying the font that our
website uses
there are actually two fonts on our
website the sans serif font and the
serif font
i'm gonna go ahead and keep the serif
one but i'm gonna modify the sans-serif
one
so first we'll find a font i really
recommend fonts.google.com
and i think i'm gonna go with this font
called work sans and now you can select
the styles you wanna use so this is
pretty important if your css
is using different varieties of the font
so the thin or medium or bold version
you need to make sure that you download
those or else all the text will appear
the same
so i'm just going to grab a few of these
styles and then google fonts gives me
this
neat little thing to embed into my head
so i'll do that again right here
you can actually see on these lines
these are where the fonts are being
imported from
so i'll paste that right here and we'll
save that and now we'll go back to our
assets
and i think the mixins.css yeah this has
where the
serif font and the sans serif font are
and it looks like it's using laura
and open sans and then after that it
shows fonts that are going to be the
fallback
but for the sans-serif font now we're
using work sans
so let's just change that we'll save it
go back to our site and it might not be
a huge change but we can refresh
and we do notice that the font does
actually change and then the last
big modification i want to make is
actually adding syntax highlighting to
our blog posts because right now all of
our code blocks are just
colored black there's no syntax
highlighting at all and it's actually
not that hard to configure
so we'll go back to vs code and we need
to go to our config file so let's open
that up
for the build settings we need to add a
highlighter
and the one we're going to use is called
rouge and just remember that any time
you modify your config.yml file you have
to stop your server so we'll hit control
c
and then rerun it just for the changes
to go into effect
but we're still not done yet because
even though we're now able to interpret
code we still don't have any css to
highlight the code
so i actually found this github repo
with some different styling for code so
i'll download this
as a zip we're going to open this up and
i'm going to create a new folder
let's do it under vendor and we're going
to call it syntax
highlighting and i'm gonna drag in these
four scss files and they're just
different themes so you don't really
need all of them
but by default our website doesn't know
that these scss files are here so we
just need to do one other thing
which is go to our main css file
styles and then we need to import the
scss highlighter that we want to use i
just copied and pasted this line
i'm going to choose the github styling
so i'll copy the relative path
and now i'm just going to paste this
here
save it and if we go back to chrome back
to our website and refresh
you see that it does make it into a code
block but on this post specifically we
don't actually specify the syntax
if we go to our other post though that
we directly imported from
rstudio and from jupyter notebooks we
should see actual
syntax highlighting here and it looks
like we do and let's just check
interactive maps
and yep this is highlighted for r so the
reason that it's not in this one is
because this is the markdown file we
made so the difference there
is when we have these code blocks we're
not specifying what language it is
whereas in these code blocks for the
other posts we actually are you can see
it says r here
and then for that other markdown it says
python so if you do want to
have that syntax highlighting you need
to make sure that you specify the actual
language
so i think that's all i'm going to
change for now but i do think this site
looks a lot better and hopefully this
gives you an idea of what jekyll can do
the last thing i want to do is just
commit and push my changes
so i'll add a message customize site and
i'll commit that
and once it's done being committed i
just come down here and push it and now
i can go back to my github repo which we
see was
just changed 23 seconds ago and if we
head over to the actual live site we see
that my changes have been made so
obviously in addition to all the changes
i made you can definitely go further i'm
going to share a link with you guys for
these jekyll plugins so if you want to
add emojis to your site or embed youtube
videos or really do any of these things
down here you're able to do that with
jekyll you just need to follow along
with the documentation
additionally you can add a custom domain
to your website so if i wanted this to
be dataslice.com
you can do that i'd recommend namecheap
or google domains and again setting it
up isn't too difficult i'll add some
documentation for that too in the
description but anyway if you make a
cool blog or find any cool chuckle
themes definitely share it down below
additionally if you have any
recommendations for future videos also
let me know
and if you found this series in any way
helpful i definitely appreciate if you
like the video and subscribe to the
channel just to stay up to date i've got
a lot of video ideas in the backlog but
thanks for watching and i'll catch you
in the next one